hey guys thanks to you what if has been
nominated for a webby
it's an international award recognizing
excellence on the internet
now we need your help take 20 seconds
out of your day go to the description
below
and vote for what if hurry you've only
got till may 7th
global warming continues to get worse
it's destroying our land and killing our
people
but what if there was a way to stop it
almost instantly we might not even need
to sacrifice our cars or
change what we eat instead we could
build a shield
to block out the sun
how would this help climate change
how possible is something like this
[Music]
and could this end up being a bad thing
for the earth this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we built a sun shield
in space a sun shield would be like
a massive umbrella in space it would
divert
rays from the sun reducing heat and
solar radiation on earth
[Music]
it's been proposed for decades by
scientists and
could one day become a reality
but there's a couple of conditions it
would cost
trillions of dollars and every country
on earth would need to be on board
easy right well let's just assume this
happens and
we'll just skip to the good stuff the
sun
shield would be created by sending small
flyers up into space
they would have incredibly thin mirrors
and would connect to make one
massive umbrella it would be half the
size of the earth and
located one and a half million
kilometers away from the planet
at this location it would be the same
distance from the earth
all year round
the shield would block out just two
percent of the sun's rays which would
reduce the earth's temperature by about
one degree
[Music]
that was the earth's temperature just
before the industrial revolution
as more flyers are added the sunshield
would
change earth's temperature gradually
this is so we don't shock every living
species on earth with a sudden
temperature change
as this happens tropical climates will
get colder
and the arctic will be able to stay
frozen for the first time in decades
decreasing the earth's temperature will
also affect the water cycle
we would have fewer heavy rain storms
hurricanes and flooding
but if we got rid of climate change
would humans continue to act as they do
today
people and big industries might still
release lots of carbon dioxide and
methane
since we'd have conquered global warming
humans might go ahead and create
even more greenhouse gases and then
they'll all get trapped in our
atmosphere
but at least we wouldn't have to worry
about climate change right
well not quite it is possible that
something could go wrong with the sun
shield like
getting hit by an asteroid or drifting
out of position
we'd have to adjust the shield every few
years and if we forgot to do that
the consequences would be devastating
if we didn't replace the shield at the
end of its 50-year life cycle
we'd be hit by a global temperature
change faster than ever before
instead of the earth's temperature
increasing over years or decades
it would happen within a couple of
months by up to three degrees
this increase in temperature would be a
huge shock to
everything on earth including the planet
itself
certain areas would become more prone to
droughts while others would have
massive floods this would destroy our
infrastructure and cities crops would
also die and
water would be harder to obtain
antarctica would be melting again while
drier areas would be burning with
wildfires
and with this happening so quickly
species wouldn't be able to adapt
and that includes us millions of people
could die and
hundreds of species could go extinct
and since people didn't decrease the
amount of carbon dioxide and methane
we released into our atmosphere when we
had the sun shield
it would be too late at this point the
earth would continue to heat up
until our planet becomes an unlivable
desert
so having a sun shield shouldn't be seen
as a bandage for climate change
instead it should be looked at as a
possible second chance for
humanity to make up for its mistakes
but due to the astronomical cost it's
unlikely a sunshield would even be built
if we had all this money shouldn't we go
to mars first
well that's a story for another
what if
you